the bank has increased bank rate from
four percent to four and a quarter
percent very much in line with
expectations
yeah before
the inflation because you said yeah they
did we think it was going to pause or do
you think did we think it was going to
raise it was a much more finely balanced
argument Kimberly as I say all of the
schools in the banking sector had led
some people to believe that the bank
might sit on its hands uh this time
around but that big increase in uh
February inflation that we got yesterday
up from 10.1 percent in January to 10.4
percent in February uh really did uh put
the tin lid on it I don't think the
monetary policy committee really had
much of a choice also bear in mind that
core inflation which is the measure
that's becoming increasingly important
to the bank of England that Rose from
4.8 to 6.2 percent that's confirmation
really that uh inflation is becoming
embedded in the UK and that it's also
being domestically generated as opposed
to being generated by uh external
factors such as the uh the war in
Ukraine which obviously uh really did
push up prices of a whole range of
Commodities a year or so ago
okay thank you very much it has just
gone 12 o'clock you're watching Sky News
and that confirmation that the bank of
England has raised its bank rate to 4.25
um let's go back to Ian King
um in is our business editories in the
city
um
and the bank of England has two core
duties doesn't it it has to hit that
Target of two percent for inflation but
it also has to protect Financial
stability how is it balancing those and
how does this decision show how it's
doing that well I'm just actually
reading the uh statement from the
monetary policy committee right now
Kimberly and they do make reference uh
to what's been going on lately uh in the
third paragraph it says they've been
large and volatile Moves In global
financial markets in particular since
the failure of Silicon Valley Bank and
in the run-up to ubs's purchase of
credit Swiss and reflecting Market
concerns about the broader impact of
these events overall government bond
yields are broadly unchanged and risky
asset prices somewhat lower than at the
time of the committee's previous meeting
so the monetary policy committee
sounding from this and so they're
relatively relaxed here's the uh key
line on that uh the bank of England's
Financial policy committee this is the
financial stability equivalent of the
monetary policy committee has briefed
the NPC about recent global banking
sector developments the FPC judges at
the UK banking system maintains robust
capital and strong liquidity positions
and is well placed to continue
supporting the economy in a wide range
of economic scenarios including a period
of higher interest rates the fpc's
assessment is that the UK banking sector
remains resilient so that really is an
indication that whilst it entered the
thinking of the monetary policy
committee this time around it wasn't
sufficient on its own to deter the
committee from uh from going for uh
another rate rise we've got the details
here of the vote the monetary policy
committee voted seven to two to increase
bank rate by a quarter of one percent uh
it says two members preferred to
maintain bank rate at four percent and I
think we can guess around that those two
will be Swati dingra and sylvana tenrero
those of course are the two Doves on the
monetary policy committee who've been
arguing for quite a while now that the
money policy committee should hold off
raising interest rates further they've
lost out and as I say I really don't
think the monetary policy committee had
a great deal of choice when core
inflation remains at elevated levels and
when the headline rate of inflation
consumer prices index is now 10.4 which
is more than five times the bank's
Central Target rate of 2 they really
didn't have much choice in interesting
you bring out Bring up the breakdown of
the vote seven to two that really is
something that you watch isn't it well I
mean the interesting thing is Kimberly
it was perfectly plausible that you
could have had a three-way split this
time around because there are some Hawks
on the MPC as well most notably
Catherine Mann uh she's been making a
series of strident speeches in which
she's made very clear that she doesn't
think the war against inflation has been
won at all and there have been some
speculation that uh she in particular
might have voted for the bank to go
further and raise interest rates by half
of one percent this time around but uh
it looks like she's uh she's back in the
pack here and gone there with the other
six members that voted for that quarter
point rise that's right it was perfectly
possible that you could have seen a
three-way split this time around uh it's
it's quite a tricky uh sort of uh thing
for the for the bank to weigh up at that
point in these situations you expect the
majority of members to go with the
governor Andrew Bailey and that
certainly seems to have been the case
this time around it wasn't always the
case Mr Bailey's predecessor but won
Mervin King now Lord king of lothbrie
there were the odd occasion in the past
where where he was out voted by other
members of the committee Mervyn King was
always seen as something of a hawk and
uh some of his uh his colleagues went
for a looser monetary policy uh we're
talking uh a period of more than 15
years ago now prior to the global
financial crisis in fact but uh it's not
it's by no means done and dusted that
the committee will always go with the
governor but that tends to be what
happens normally
okay and we've got two graphs I want to
bring to you now one is the rate since
November 2021
there you go yeah so yeah this is this
is the 11th time of course uh in
consecutive meetings that the bank has
raised uh Bank rates
um that's uh that's the term that it
uses for uh what we used to call Base
rates what is really interesting
Kimberly is that uh you go back to the
end of the left-hand side of that scale
where interest rates of course were uh
uh 0.1 which uh was a post pandemic uh
it was a response to the pandemic that
was in December 2021 and whilst the bank
of England has had a lot of criticism
for being behind the curve in the jargon
and not having responded to uh signs
that inflation was building up in the
economy during 2021. it is actually
worth reminding people that of all the
major central banks around the world the
European Central Bank the U.S federal
reserve the Swiss National Bank which I
should say by the way raised interest
rates today by half of one percent the
bank of England was actually the first
major Central Bank in the uh G7 to
actually start raising interest rates
back in December 2021 although it's also
worth in mind that other central banks
have raised interest rates by even more
for example the U.S federal reserve of
course last night raised uh their policy
rate fed funds by a quarter of a point
last night their uh policy range is now
four and three quarter to five percent
so a lot of other central banks around
the world have been moving a lot more
rapidly than the bank of England has